[Musique]
on a besoin de ça parce que jusqu'à
présent on ne mesure pas l'impact
environnemental des pratiques qui sont
développés en agriculture or le problème
c'est que il faut donner aujourd'hui aux
décideurs en fait de l'agriculture une
mesure de l'impact des pratiques pour
les aider à faire des à prendre des
décisions éclairées les aider à choisir
en fait dans leur cahier des charges
pour les industriels dans leur pratique
pour les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui l'agriculture a conduit à ce
que la peu près la moitié des sols
agricoles mondiaux sont abîmés ou très
abîmé on a une régression une baisse de
la biodiversité qui est considérable on
a perdu à peu près la moitié des stocks
du must de carbone dans le sol depuis
une quarantaine d'années et ça on le
mesure on mesure la catastrophe après
coup
dès lors qu'on se met à mesurer on
change ces comportements c'est comme le
l'indicateur de vitesse dans une voiture
si vous en avez pas vous rouler aussi
vite que possible si vous en avez un et
qu'en plus il ya un certain nombre de
réglementations un certain nombre de
choses qui vous indiquent qu'il faut pas
roulait pas trop vite vous faites
attention c'est la même chose sur
l'impact sur les sols dès lors que vous
mesurez votre impact sur l'environnement
à travers la mesure de la santé des sols
vous êtes capable de changer vos
comportements personne n'a envie et
surtout pas les agriculteurs de détruire
l'environnement qui les fait vivre
on travaille pour des grands groupes on
travaille aussi pour des états on a
signé un accord avec le gouvernement de
côte d'ivoire pour suivre l'impact
environnemental des pratiques agricoles
qui est pour certifier les filières de
cacao par exemple les principales
filières d'exportation ça rentre dans le
cas de legacy programme qui a été
annoncé au cours de la cop 15 qui est un
gros programme d'amélioration de
l'impact des pratiques agricoles de
restauration des sols etc pour avoir une
agriculture extrêmement durable et avoir
des filières qui s'inscrivent dans la
pérennité